I think we got a do not spoon I don't
think I think if we don't do not spoon
now right I mean isn't nothing what
we're all about learning a lot about
television Conan and Andy are teaching
me a lot not spoon Jesus what I got to
be there for my colonoscopy tomorrow
it's sick why do I have to be there you
don't have to work you said I had to be
there oh no I insist I've seen it pal oh
yeah I want someone I want someone with
a gentle hand well I love that drug that
going out to be drugs the greatest thing
I'm not wavering that it's the only time
I've ever been happy
I'm not kidding if the only time I've
ever been happy as when you were
penetrated and drugged no I didn't feel
bad at all it's that [ __ ] drug they
give you yeah and the penetration no I
don't care about that part well and I
want to Wow
finally release from the shackles of my
own self hey not spoons act 1 and act 2
we'll be right back with more nuts poon
should we shoot a quick thing where I'm
like hi I'm Conan O'Brien if you thought
this sketch could have gone longer let
us know because there's a lot of places
we could go with nuts poon contacts that
team cocoa donut spoon not that spoon
how to make it longer suggestions we're
dying to hear from you why not
[Music]
you